SPEAKER 1: That's a tremendous
philosophic proposition,
and the ultimate source
of human freedom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But what does it mean,
all men are created equal,
when obviously, by
the way, they are not?
Like, look around the table.
I'm old, you're young.
Boys and girls.
Large and small.
Younger and older.
You're just a baby, aren't you?
SPEAKER 2: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: He's a sophomore.
He's a precocious sophomore,
this old Christian here.
So we're not equal, right?
Compare children and dogs.
The most important
comparison, by the way,
in the entire academic
world, key to understanding
all nature, is to compare
children and dogs.
I don't like cats.
I don't compare them.
But children and dogs.
And what is it about the
children and the dogs?
SPEAKER 3: You can
raise them just
about the same way
when they're young.
But then at some point, the
children start speaking,
and somehow they've picked
up on how people act
and how people interact.
SPEAKER 1: They talk.
Yeah, the specific
thing they do, see.
In my family, the
children are grown now,
and we have these two boxers,
and they're really great.
One of them is a
three-legged dog,
and he's the happiest
dog we ever had.
And the dogs are
everywhere, wherever we are.
So you guys are all coming
over to my house for dinner,
and you will find that you'll
be dining with the dogs.
And when we were
raising the kids,
the dogs were always there.
And after about a year and a
half, the kids started talking
and the dogs never did.
And they'd all heard
exactly the same things.
So this talking--
Aristotle says that the gift
of speech, which is identical,
he claims, to reason
or rationality,
they are the same thing.
The argument is when
you are talking,
you are thinking to yourself.
You are thinking out loud.
And when you are thinking,
you are talking to yourself.
It's the same thing.
Now, somehow this
capacity we have that
makes us human-- there's some
respect in which we are all
created equal.
And where I think that
is is this phenomenon
of the dogs and the kids.
Dogs at various
times in their lives
are greatly preferable
to children.
But they're not the same kind of
thing, else they would say so,
and they never do.
Last night the dogs were
talking to us, as dogs talk.
And Aristotle says
animals use their voices
to indicate pleasure and pain.
People speak to distinguish
the just from the unjust.
This whole thing is a statement
of the just and the unjust,
and it depends on
this simple point.
This is what all men
are created equal means.
You are the King of England, and
you ride in a golden carriage,
and everybody salutes
you, and all fear you.
But you know, when you
were a year and a half old,
you started doing something
that no animal has ever done.
And no one taught
you to do that.
You just started doing it.
And it wasn't because
you were born royal,
it's because you were born
human, and so were we.
It just means that.
And born in this gift, you see,
that we can speak and therefore
say, that thing and that thing
is the same kind of thing.
And it doesn't
make any difference
if it's your kid or
somebody else's, you
can't treat it like a dog,
because it is not a dog.
And no king can
treat it like a dog,
because it is not a dog to him,
either, because it's not a dog.
Once the ground is laid
for that, then, of course,
Thomas Jefferson can write,
in the last serious letter
he wrote, some are not born
with saddles on their backs,
nor others booted and spurred to
ride them by the grace of God.
The king can rightly
put a harness
on the horses that
pull his carriage,
but he can't do that to
people unless they volunteer.
You see, that's a tremendous
philosophic proposition
and the ultimate source
of human freedom.
And this, by the way, is the
greatest political statement
of that in all history.
SPEAKER 4: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.